各位热爱创作，希望通过剧本写作接单赚钱的同学们，大家好。
跟大家通报一个重要的信息啊。
咱们的编剧课已经迎来了一次重大的转型，正是从一个。
正式从单纯的教学平台转型成为编剧教学加剧本接单的综合性平台，以帮助更多的零基础小白通过学习做到接单变现，也真正践行了咱们一直以来的教学理念，也就是人人都能写剧本，人人都有代表。
咱们的课程体系已经运行了6年了。
6年来呢覆盖了上百万的。
跟随咱们系统学习的同学就有6万多。
现在相当一部分都工作在影视和传媒行业。
每一天呀都有咱们学员的影视作品在上线。随着咱们课程影响力的扩大啊，找我们的甲方也越来。
要么来约剧本，要么来找编剧。所以我们的编剧课啊后来就建立了编剧人才库。
发展到现在呢有几千名编剧。
目前是行业最大产能最强的连居组。
咱们编剧库的这一次升级和转型。
其实主要针对的是短剧板块。
短剧大家看到了啊，现在非常。
我们针对短剧板块升级有两个原因，第一是订单太多了。
现在每个月都有几百个短剧剧本的订单等着同学们来写。第二个原因啊是短剧赛道对于小白新手来说。
咱们的同学呢大部分是小白零基础，通过我们的课程学会了写剧本。这部分同学呢把短句作为敲门砖，赚到自己的第一笔片酬。
短剧的快速发展，加上AI技术的成熟。
创作门槛进一步降低了，内容写作呢也。
所以在这里，我欢迎所有怀揣创作梦想的同学加入我。
在我们这里，只要你想写能写，才华一定不会被埋。